hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to let's play which oh oh
I'm playing uh oh yeah this is a game
that was suggested actually a long time
ago by one person named A5 Miranda and
they suggested it every time they
commented every single message they ever
sent to me was play witch play witch why
don't you play witch yet why aren you
playing witch yet so I'm playing witch
I'm just a few months late
go okay
so use the okay WD is
okay all right so I actually don't know
anything about this game oh hello a it's
so
pretty no no okay uh left click I
figured that out for myself o
hello
oh hi I hear
something a heartbeating
h
I I'm actually not sure what I'm
supposed to oh Crouch with right Mouse
button really that's
weird all righty then click click click
click all right kind of creepy it's
really dark and dank and fuzzy not sure
what's going
on either way I hear a thumpy thump but
I don't I don't see a thumpy thump oh
the heart oh that should have been much
more obvious but I have the key right
don't I have the key how do I use the
key maybe that's not the key to that I
know H what's
this Ah that's what that key is for wait
this just a
bathroom oh hello is that another key oh
what did I get it or did it fall down
the drain what say what say
what a come on I have a key have a key
icon I hear the thumpy thumb okay let's
go
upstairs hello is anybody
home nice shiny
lights big oh there we
go okay oh
hello okay person key door not key plus
two what what's that supposed to mean
okay let me figure this out obviously
it's a riddle of Epic
Proportions okay person key
Escape no key plus two people oh two
people plus key equals not Escape oh so
two people with the key can I don't know
I don't know oh what the
hell it's a
face it's locked good I didn't want to
go in there anyway God of course
not all right it looks freaky in here
not really not sure what to
expect uh maybe there's like another
closet under the stairs or ah
exit oh well that's a
problem oh that's Birds I thought that
was like a secret coded message but no
apparently it is not okay
so I seem to be running in
circles crouchy
uh hear the thumpy thump wait a minute
can I get through there no no no no what
happened to the
key I want the key give me the dang key
oh there we go oh I need to figure out a
way to get that
off ah what the oh hello I don't think I
need that I'm pretty sure what is that a
showerhead H I don't even know so I got
to find a way to get them that
off
how if I know why would I know I'm just
a big dumb idiot can I turn a light on
what's with the lighting in this place
it's all freaky and
monochromatic good word Mark Sell five
bam I would do cuz none of you can f
high five me right now so I got to sell
five
okay I am running in
circles there was nothing up here why
did I even have to unlock this room why
did I even why did I even have to unlock
the
room I couldn't go any this weird door
with the head in
it I don't know I don't know can't open
anything I can't do it I can't do it I
got a tiny dumb little Markiplier
brain what am I supposed to
do what am I supposed to do why is it
always get like really dark when I walk
in here for some reason oh yeah thumpy
thump I know you're there I'm just Spam
clicking now just in case I miss
something and I'm not seeing it right
away no no no okay okay why did I have
to open those what was the point of
that ah sorry got sick of not making
progress I'm allergic to [__] come
on come
on what am I going to do I can't see a
damn thing everything is my vision is so
bad everything is blurry totally
colorblind also I'm
stupid I got problems man I got problems
big
problems okay what am I supposed to do
what I want to do H birdies I want to be
free I want to free them I Want to Be
Free what is
this I want to
free cuz I'm
free Free
Falling Free
Falling cuz I'm
[Music]
free uh free for oh man okay all right I
don't see I don't get it I'm I'm a big
Ed [__] I don't even know what the point
of this game
is
whoa what did I just open what was that
something opened what what what
what what
what something opened something
opened I heard it
dang it what open oh maybe I maybe I
opened things on the other side of this
door that's probably what happened all
right poop
monkeys butt
potato potato butt I can't I I do not
know I'm I'm like I'm doing bad I'm
doing piss
poorly I'm doing teror
bad
why why
hi I got
nothing I've got nothing to live
for how do I bash things with my
fistic I
can't handle
it I just got to click it enough until
it'll break right right right right
right okay all right I'm a uh I'm uh I
kind of failed here I kind of failed in
in
hardcore I think I'm going to do the
trick where I accelerate in time again
cuz usually future me in a much better
position I'm dumb past me this pass me
cuz God even you it's passed me cuz you
werey hang on let me let me jump into
the
[Applause]
future
back okay pass me was a stupid
[__] how stupid can you
be everybody laughed at my past
self I don't know which direction to
point but
oh oh okay anyway so the key right here
so we got this so let's go in this
second room
yay
Yahoo
oh I did open one of the
drawers what did oh
[Music]
oh no what you got a
key
okay what
huh
[Music]
H key equal head heart okay do
key oh God damn
it
no go go go where's the key a don't
turn
close the damn door how how do I what do
I do I can't get in the heart oh God oh
God oh God oh God oh God oh
God oh God oh God
God you got the key wait I saw it
I saw it swing swanging in your hand
give me that give me I'm seeing right up
your
dress don't look up her
dress what the hell did
happened what was
that oh
my the key I I still don't know how to
get the key out of that one oh man I
don't know where where did she
go I don't know I don't know what
happened what
happened what what
happened did I bug her I might I might
yeah I killed her yeah I'm I'm the
best yeah
ah oh there you are what are you doing
hi why'd you come up here can I look up
your dress again and you'll disappear is
that how this work oh
my it was so amazing what I saw that it
just my your mind's just going
to okay so anyway so I don't know where
she went this
time where did she
go where' she go she really doesn't like
you looking up her skirt I don't know
why H there you are hi hello hello baby
you want a shoulder rub oh okay you all
right so um I don't know how to get the
key of
her Ah that's still creepy still creepy
lady okay turn around bam
oh hi can you uh do something about this
whole situation we got going on here
about hey you concern help maybe maybe
baby oh come on baby come on baby you
know you know oh yeah that's right
follow
[Music]
me God that's so
creepy oh what do I do she's so creepy
she's so freaky good God I don't know
what to do I don't know I don't know
ah she's always right behind me it's not
fair I don't know what to do I don't
think there was a key
like God I don't think there the number
three key is in the sink but I don't
know how to bust it open what was that
oh oh oh yes [__] monkey
wrench come on baby yeah that's right
follow
me all right follow
me
yeah how how come on baby follow me up
the stairs again I'm going to get you
your head or
heart I don't know I don't know what the
symbology means
symbology okay what's in here hello oh
God hi you're uh you're kind of O A ging
up in here created by Mike enel dark
basic professional DBP Collision dll
enhanced animations and easy rotate
enhan this dark basic I don't think I've
ever heard of that one dark AI dark Shi
ah I might have to look into that cuz
this the animation's on that that lady
are pretty well done okay what's this
that's to the Head where's the heart
one where's the
heart I'm running away out of time so
I'll get the head and I'll do the heart
ending later I don't
know okay I'm going get jeez I mean come
on where's your head in the toilet of
course it is there it is
got it got it oh your
eyes uh okay can I what that's really
freaking
freaky come Lady Lady Lady Lady oh okay
all right good you gonna give me the key
now good God that is
freaky
oh God oh God the freaking
thing hey ah oh God okay so what do you
did you drop the key um key key key key
key oh hello there you are hi can I have
the key thank you way
out can I get out now than go
tiger tiger uhoh oh no she going to kill
me only one can escape CH kill me I'll
kill you
first no no don't do it no get
away oh you miss a
fud hi thank you no please D now my my
my clean owie owie ow
ow I'm I'm a tough son of a [__]
if didn't
hurt I'm still
alive I'm still I'm still alive I'm not
dead yet
feel
better I get it now witch head or heart
I don't know how to get the heart but if
you guys tell me I'll play it the hard
ending but anyway that was witch that
was witch so thank you all so much for
watching I guess that's it so that was a
fun little game and if anybody knows
what dark basic professional is that uh
another game engine software that I
don't know about um just let me know
guys cuz I'm I'm always interested in
that sort of technical stuff so thank
you all so much for watching and as as
always I'll see you in the next video
byebye